hey i'm josh peck i play scott turner in
the new disney plus series
turner and hooch and i'm here with
buzzfeed to talk about my first times
the first time i realized i was famous i
would imagine it was something that my
mom told me
my mom uses any level of celebrity i
have for her own selfish interests
all the time if you've ever talked to my
mom and you're a customer service person
you know that barbara peck's son is josh
peck and that she
expects some special treatment similarly
if you're a hostess at the cheesecake
factory
she's gonna drop my name for a better
table and maybe some extra bread
anyway i think the first time that i
felt slightly remotely famous was being
probably was like 16
walking through the burbank media center
in burbank california
and getting recognized by a mob of kids
who watched
my show on nickelodeon when you get
recognized that close to a food court
it sticks with you my first
behind-the-scenes memory of shooting
drake and josh i remember specifically
it was
in one of the first six episodes that we
shot we lose
a baby that were babysitting on the roof
of a house
and the bit was that the baby starts to
pee on us
as we're trying to give it a bath which
i have a two and a half year old son
this is not far-fetched it happens all
the time and i just remember i was
standing with miranda and i
who played my little sister and they had
all this piping with the baby like
all the special effects piping to spray
like water at us
to do the gag and of course they yelled
action and the baby started to pee on us
in real life and i just remember
thinking
wow this is a job i'm being paid to do
this
it's pretty wild memory but awesome oh
man
first celebrity crush i've talked about
this before it was jennifer love hewitt
in the movie can't hardly wait
i think i saw her in that movie i must
have been 12 and
i remember it clicking in my mind going
i like girls
girls are awesome fast forward about a
decade later i was at a starbucks
in the valley where crazy things happen
and i ran into
jennifer love hewitt i didn't have the
guts to say anything to her but we
shared about three and a half seconds of
eye contact
and in that moment i felt like she knew
what she had meant to me at that time
and she appreciated it first rule you
really wanted an audition for but didn't
get
oh my gosh this is such a great show
buzzfeed you guys
are really good at what you do i
remember i auditioned for the movie
holds based on the book and i was like
maybe 14 or 15 years old shia labeouf
and
who's a buddy of mine now we were both
you know on our kids shows
i remember going to that audition and
feeling like great and then going to the
call back i was like wow this really
could happen i love the book maybe this
is mine and then
hearing the chai got it and just being
like totally heartbroken
and then watching the movie and being
like oh man this guy is
very good very very good i i think holes
that was the one i would have been out
there eating onions in the middle
of the desert but i think shia did a
better job first famous friend you made
in hollywood
i'm not sure if it was like the first
but it was significant because he was
like properly famous and someone i
looked up to and i couldn't believe
he knew that i existed so my first
famous friend in hollywood was
i went to performing arts high school in
new york a lot of actors went there like
claire danes and jesse eisenberg and my
buddy victor rasik who was on a show
called how to make it in america and it
was him
and kid cuddy and i remember one night i
was at the club
because i'm cool i was like i don't know
22 years old
and i run into victor and we're chopping
it up and it's just so good to see you
know an old high school friend and he's
like yo
i'm here with some of the cast from the
show do you want to come meet like kid
cuddy
scott he goes by scott like his real
friends
which i am one of i'm nervous but okay
yes i would love to meet these people
and i remember i walk up to scott cubby
and he looks at me and goes oh
he's like i love drake and josh and i
was like i love
you kid scott cuddy we wound up talking
the whole night he couldn't have been a
better dude i remember he was like yo
take my number like
stay in touch and i'm like cool joke
we're never gonna stay in touch kid cudi
and he texted me the next day
and was like yo do you want to come by
the studio and listen to my new album
and i was like
of course i want to do that and i
wouldn't listen to his new album we
haven't talked a lot since then but it
was nice
it was a great two days first thing you
remember about the audition process okay
so the first thing i remember about the
audition process for turner and hooch
was
i'm playing you know scott turner tom
hanks son from the original movie i
remember them telling me so for the
audition
we're gonna have a real dog there and it
wasn't the french mastiff
that is hooch it was like just whatever
gigantic dog was available that day i
think it was a greyhound
so i had a real dog to act off of
and the producer said yo improvise
find it we're not sort of rigid when it
comes to this because we know that
the dogs have already done their job by
being this cute and awesome
and if they don't necessarily stand on
their mark for too long
we gotta work around them and we did my
first dog or pet was
my dog sushi who was a bichon
i miss you every day sush he was great
i'm pretty sure i was
really allergic to him and i think it
contributed to my childhood asthma but i
don't resent him for that i resent my
mom
i'm just kidding mom oh this is great
first untrue rumor you heard about
yourself was that i was dead
people have been saying i've been dead
for a long time i think it was
predominantly
a rumor in latin america that i had
passed away
i'm sorry to tell you or may be happy to
tell you that i'm still very much alive
and happy to be here
unless this is a simulation but still
then we're all kind of
in more than one world i don't know so
my first reaction i had to finding out i
was going to be a dad
you know i do comedy at different
colleges where i go and i
you know get to visit all these colleges
across the country and i do like a
little bit of stand-up and kind of like
a moderated q a where i talk about my
life
and stories and experiences i remember i
had a week where
i had done like four or five in a row
every day i was traveling to a new city
and waking up at 6 a.m and doing the
college at night and then flying to a
new city
i was flying home back to la on friday
morning and i thought
you know josh you deserve a break just
take the weekend off
don't think about work this couldn't
have gone better and and then i lend and
i get a text from my wife saying hey i'm
not far i'll come pick you up from lax i
and i think how lucky am i and i get in
the car
and we're driving for about three
seconds and she pulls out the pregnancy
test
and she was like and i was like
oh great great
luckily i had the weekend to kind of
like wrap my head around it because i
was so excited and
it's what i'd always wanted but i don't
know if you're ever totally prepared to
get that news
it wasn't exactly the most restful
weekend i was expecting but
it was definitely the most awesome
weekend first bad
date experience oh man to be quite
honest i haven't like been on like a lot
of traditional
dates i i do remember though once going
out with this
very lovely person and i think she
thought
or maybe i was mistaken in the dress
code
for the date like what was going to be
appropriate i showed up to pick her up
to go get dinner and
she was dressed as though we were going
to a
ball like it was it was very formal
and very dressed up and i was like i
don't and i'm like in like less
than this a t-shirt and jeans and
probably
like shoes with no socks literally
a step above college frat attire i'm not
sure whether it was
embarrassing for me or for her maybe it
was just not great for either of us the
first thing that i'll do
post pandemic i'm a schwitz guy i like a
nice sauna
experience i like the cold plunge there
are like a couple great places
in la if you're like oh i'd like to get
a nice little schvitz
before i shower up feel like they've all
been closed and you can't do that
it would be nice to do that without any
fear or worries i don't know if that's a
weird answer but
it's my truth thank you guys for
watching i hope you enjoy
my new show turner and hoot streaming
now on disney plus
you